who's going to fight the wars yeah right
who is going to put freaking black paint
on their face
and pick up a weapon and crawl across
the beach and start killing enemy like
that's a certain type of human being
right that's the type of human being
that may not correctly reintegrate into
society this dude might end up robbing
banks when he gets back
it's the Martin Watson problem yeah it's
the Martin Watson problem which we'll
get to but but we do have to think about
that and and when you have guys you know
we we talked about obedience as a
characteristic being look is it is it
good to have some obedience yes it is
and was Darby maybe too far on the
spectrum of being too obedient yes but
then you get some other guys that are on
the other end of the spectrum that you
want you want to have someone that's
going to be like I don't care what you
tell me to do I'm gonna go attack this
Machine Gun Nest get out of my way you
want to have some guys like that